would you be interested in returning to
qui-gon if given the opportunity let's
see
come on yeah yeah yeah i think
um
if it was a film oh nice try yeah
when it comes to tv almost no
[Music]
uh
all right well liam neeson we've never
been more thrilled to be lied to
because we love seeing you back in this
and of course again we we thank uh chris
killian and the wonderful folks at
comicbook.com for getting that scoop
because he gave us this wonderful
opportunity to test an actor's ability
to act and he did a pretty good job i
think he had a pretty good answer it's
just you know we know if you're going to
do voices and clone wars you're going to
be able to suit up as qui-gon
on the volume green screen set wherever
you did that and uh hey we're going to
actually revisit that episode of clone
wars uh right here in this episode
because we're going to talk forest
ghosts today folks welcome back to new
rock stars obi-wan kenobi ended by
debunking liam neeson's claims that he
would only do a star wars film by
bringing back the force ghost of qui-gon
jinn who saw every disgusting thing
obi-wan did alone in that cave
but how does force ghosting work exactly
and since kenobi will learn this skill
at some point in the future what kind of
training will these two
jokers go through over the next nine
years will it take them off world once
again
tell us the truth
[Music]
this is wikileaks it's new rockstars
weekly discussion of the biggest news in
star wars i'm eric voss i'm here with my
good friend tommy bechtold tommy
tommy i'm on vacation baby i'm wearing
my fun
kind of grogu hat that i'm not 100 sure
disney did sell this in their store so
they did sign off on this but i don't
really it kind of looks like max rebo
and yoda
had like an illicit
love affair so i've got this puppy dog
ears but it's not just that i'm also
joined by
a ridiculously expensive bb-8 balloon i
bought from my girlfriend's son and if
you thought that was all you're wrong
because she also demanded
a chewbacca doll
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well our our disney overlords very much
appreciate your um due pain we have to
spend at least like uh four thousand
dollars at the disney parks and resorts
uh were required by law or they liked us
or they shocked us yeah we we've talked
about the champion kiss you know the
triple shaped throne the lolo drones
that float around yeah they are
invisible and they are swarming around i
was in magic kingdom yesterday and i got
a touch of the champion kiss and i'd be
honest not enough baby powder in the
world to get that off
well i had to show off some merch i got
because i did an improv show last week
yeah san francisco and i was visited by
a wonderful friend of the channel our
friend mezzo who uh gifted me with my
favorite gift i think i've ever received
in terms of star wars merch i've never
actually owned uh like a light up one of
these the last one that i owned was uh
was like from the prequel area where it
fanned out you know uh i was obsessed
with those but this one's a legit one it
lights up oh my god
oh it makes sounds oh my god
and right now it's on rotating color
setting i think or no no i picked green
incredible what a gift
i love it
that is so cool
it's like i love this gift thank you so
much for this and perhaps the greatest
gift attending a live comedy show
oh well
lucky here i'll respond a second
sorry
i don't know what's going on oh you're
sam jackson now
i wish i was here i'm just gonna
you just smack smash it now
oh wow that i mean come on that is
freaking sweet yeah you know normally i
would i would laugh at the idea of a
comedy show being a gift but mezzo was
lucky to catch us at probably the best
show we've done so far that was a really
fun night eric i'm so sorry we've been
conditioned i meant the gift was their
attendance at your comedy show yes the
gift of a friend or supporter coming and
watching our part in the top shows but
but yes i have no doubt i've seen you
improvise probably a thousand times and
each time is a gift for me to see my man
pretty ricky up there doing what he does
best
that's kind of you to say yes but you
are right uh someone attending an improv
show of someone else that is worth its
weight in gold
it cannot be understated or overstated
as we continue to process the ride we
just went on in obi-wan kenobi's six
episodes we are left with the mystery of
the force ghost
and we thought we would spend this
episode explaining the spiritual history
of this process what it tells us about
obi-wan and qui-gon's future over the
next several years until we
chronologically next see obi-wan
technically when maul catches up with
him in star wars rebels a twin sons
episode an amazing episode um so but
there's like a long history we gotta see
what turns his hair white other than you
know just just old age but you know
there's still a story to be told there
uh before we jump into our discussion
today another reminder that new rock
stars will be live in austin on july 1st
through july 3rd for rtx that's rooster
t's podcast festival it's gonna be tommy
and me plus jessica clements and phil
molina doing a live show saturday july
2nd it's part of the festival it's just
going to be so much fun i have uh
i'm working on a really fun show i'm not
telling tommy or the others about it
i love it it's going to be
a saucy saucy [ __ ] saucy
yes i need some barbecue yes i need at
least uh at least one at least one meal
to be some torchy's tacos
or some or some street tacos i mean
street tacos are the best in austin but
i just i have fond memories of torches i
at least got to stop by absolutely
anyway uh so join us in austin if you
live in that area of texas you know
we're gonna have a lot of fun it's gonna
be a fun weekend so click the link in
the description use the promo code new
rockstars it's all one word for a
discounted ticket price we hope to see
you there but you know if you don't live
in texas or in the austin area don't
worry uh we're gonna be hopefully
getting on the road a lot more here in
new
rocks uh
so this won't be the last time we do a
live show
keep your ears open
yeah i will go i want to check it out
i've never been there
charlottesville keep your ears open
dirt raleigh durham
keep them shut we're never coming uh
yeah we're never going to durham i just
finished the staircase i know what
happens that's right michael peterson is
coming for us
uh also this is your last chance to get
our limited edition latest obsession
kenobi inspired empire's most wanted
shirt available at near
exercisemerch.com it's the best way to
support us here at new rockstars when
you get one of these you will unlock the
added option to ride in a custom shout
out that will appear at the bottom of
these after shows for example matthew
says eric and tommy you guys rock who
wouldn't want to land on back told four
that's right i mean people are beginning
that's really catching on is canon that
the the moon that uh vader and obi-wan
fought on in the finale of kenobi was in
fact called bechtold four uh where are
beth told one through three i'll never
tell although we're gonna try to
subpoena you for that information
because the families want answers
quentin says hayden's smile is as
digital as the scorpion from the mummy
hey i don't think that's fair to say
quentin i think the i think the cgi was
actually pretty good now i'm i assume
you're referring to hayden smile from
episode five and yeah smiles are very
hard to animate uh very hard to animate
it's not so i think he still smiled it
was a hayden smile this was the vfx
version of his face mapped on it was
really the animator's smile and yeah
that that is kind of where he started to
see some flaws but to compare it to
dwayne the rock johnson in the mummy my
friend no way come on that's not fair
you don't always have to agree with us
that's okay that's right uh and then
daniel says
this lit and whatever this is daniel i
refer to you yeah everything is lit this
is liz
thank you daniel yeah and thank you
matthew thank you quintet thank you
everybody who has supported us with uh
with uh uh checking out our merch and
supporting the channel again that is the
best way to support what we do
here um all right let's dive into our
discussion today tommy what are we
talking about eric i'm not on the break
room this week because as i've said i'm
on vacation so i'm gonna have to get all
my swears out here so please forgive me
when i say thank ferret how the fact do
force ghosts work
good question tommy so the concept of
the force ghost goes back to the
original trilogy of course obi-wan
kenobi's disembodied voice in a new hope
and the empire strikes back and then his
ghostly form and return of the jedi and
an early script draft after return of
the jedi established that returning as a
forced spirit like this could only be
attained by users of the light side of
the force not by sith and that's why
it's so meaningful to see anakin's
ghosts return alongside obi-wan and yoda
even though it's still currently a bit
confusing for anyone who watched the
prequel trilogy first that hayden's
force ghost appears there despite
sebastian shaw being the one under the
mask when luke unmasks him but i just
say give those lucasfilm mad men some
time i guarantee you they will replace
shaw's face with hayden scarface
eventually using vfx technology and then
billions of voices will scream out in
terror while another billion of voices
who grew up with the prequels will
scream even louder that the prequel
trilogy is the most important of the
three trilogies and that everything dave
filoni does is okay that's right
i think
i can't wait for that debate because you
know it's inevitable you know they're
going to be playing space every semester
it's going to be worked on now it's it's
very close on the christmas list yeah
it's gonna it's just inevitable i
i don't want that to happen i'm not as
much as i like hayden i like the
redemption that he's getting through the
obi-wan kenobi series i think it was a
travesty that his force ghost was put
there at the end of return of the jedi
it it the the moment that mark hamill
and sebastian shaw connect with each
other is sacred to me and i hate i hate
that they just put uh a different face i
think it's really screw with people and
put james earl jones's face in there i
mean i'd be okay with you
that is a compromise what happened there
okay i could get on board i can get on
board with james
yeah that would be okay by me um so a
jedi becoming a force ghost was a skill
previously known to the jedi order but
it was lost to time it was rediscovered
by qui-gon jinn from the shaman of the
wills this was explored in a season six
arc of clone wars the episode's titled
voices destiny and sacrifice for many
years we thought these were the final
released episodes of clone wars before
it was canceled uh but it was of course
brought back for season seven but this
remains a very interesting arc that i
highly recommend everyone goes back to
watch because we learn a lot about the
mysticism of the force from these
episodes yoda learns through these
forced priestesses about a more
spiritual side of the force uh these
force priestesses uh dwell in the
wellspring of life that's that's the
fourth planet that is considered to be
the origin of the midichlorians um we
don't know a lot about this planet and i
love that it's such a mystery so um
qui-gon jinn learned from the shaman of
the wills uh qui-gon jinn's force ghost
appears in these episodes and that's
something they start to go into uh now
you know the wills the wills come from
george lucas's original draft of a new
hope when it was originally titled the
adventures
of luke star killer as taken from the
journal of the wills the idea was that
the wills were these advanced alien
beings from another era who kept all of
these legends the star wars stories in
their journals and then passed down
these myths as their like biblical myths
and their parables that they learned
from thus a long time ago in a galaxy
far away it was meant to be like this
like a bedtime story or a bible story
that they were telling their kids um the
wills came back in rogue one jared emway
was not a jedi remember he was a
guardian of the wills he comes from that
same devout religious tradition as the
shaman of the wills so qui-gon
was working with the shaman of the wills
was unable to complete his training of
course because maul killed him in
phantom menace uh but qui-gon continued
to speak through various disembodied
voices his voice called out to anakin
during attack of the clones when anakin
was slaughtering the tuscans he spoke to
yoda after order 66 and revenge of the
sith but yes somewhere in this time
qui-gon was able to uh create a bodied
ghost spirit of himself to talk to
people now the sequel films further
expanded the actual abilities of force
ghost films in the last jedi yoda's
force ghost could manipulate the weather
to cause lightning to strike a tree and
then he knocked luke in the face with a
stick and then at rise of skywalker
luke's force ghost picked up a
lightsaber and then raised the x-wing
from the water and again dark side users
are not able to return as force ghosts
but their spiritual essence can inhabit
objects that they miss example being
darth moment possessing a mask this was
seen in the 2017 darth vader lord of the
sith comics by charles sol again i
highly recommend you read those yes like
whether you loved obi-wan kenobi as a
series or if you didn't love it
if just read those comics if you were
interested enough in this in these
characters to watch that series you will
not be disappointed in these comics i
think these comics
my opinion far better than the six
episodes of obi-wan kenobi i just love
those comics so much um now the question
now is can qui-gon give obi-wan this
training on tatooine like in a remote
learning session or would it be better
for obi-wan to retrace yoda steps in the
steps qui-gon went on uh or at least the
steps that we saw yoda go on in those uh
clone wars episodes and uh obi-wan won't
have to leave tatooine for that uh the
implication for the final episode was
that kenobi was packing up his cave and
moving further away from the lars
homestead because he did not need to
keep as constant of an eye on luke and
then could pursue some other hobbies in
his downtime yes so what will kenobi's
uh forest ghost training look like could
he go to moriband as we saw yoda do
could he visit the wellspring of life
hook up with some of those force priests
sign up for some seminars score some
colored sashes
g j brandon oh my gosh
yes
it says honey honey honey no no no i've
been through this myself the volleyball
is not worth it here here here come just
help me hide some guns beneath luke's
pillow 4 a.m volleyball do it
uh yeah so i just want to discuss do you
think qui-gon jinn
and his force goes they're going to lead
obi-wan off planet again in order to get
this training i mean i don't know how
we're going to see it i actually
wouldn't mind if they just went back to
do it as a comic book you know like i i
don't know rather than doing it as a
kenobi uh season two i know i know we
all want to see you and mcgregor play
kenobi as much as possible if there's
any other way for it to happen we're
going to want to see it but
i think the adventures of qui-gon and
obi-wan are are much more fun possibly
seen through a graphic novel or a comic
book series uh
i just uh
i do think that that he is going to stay
with him now i think eventually the
nature of a force ghost is not that it's
like a it's not like uh drop dead fred
or beetlejuice where it's just attached
at your hip the nature is it appears
when you need it when you call out to it
in times of of a need for wisdom or for
help so i don't think he's necessarily
going to be like you know they're not
going to be playing uh
uh you're my best friend by queen you
know as as they skip through the the the
sands of texas why not i like him
and aren't fan fake eric but you know
you won't let me publish it
there's way too much nudity and like
it's not it's not sexual it's just like
cruel well sometimes when i write
obi-wan pulled out his saber i'm not
always talking about his genitalia i am
talking about his lightsaber but most of
the time you are correct i'm talking
about his dick
um you're on to something tommy i think
uh doing another uh live action series
isn't the only way that we can explore
this so if they do do a season two of
obi-wan kenobi this is what i'd want uh
i want obi-wan to go on his own
spiritual journey hang out with qui-gon
a little bit uh even if qui-gon like
disappears a little bit now it's just
liam neeson doing voice-over
i don't need uh i don't need the
skywalker kids to show back up but i
think there's another alternative here
we could see like an animated season of
this yeah we don't have to do it in live
action yeah you know like i'd be okay
with just like uh
a prequel series to uh or like a
spin-off from bad batch or something
like that absolutely like there's
there's other ways to do this that
aren't necessarily the actors in live
action you can save a bit of budget on
it and uh and and make it more
spiritual mystical and really just go
crazy with the animation the way that
those clone wars episodes did in fact
that's kind of what i want like we're
seeing we're getting like a tales from
the jedi series
we're exploring more in animation i
think this would be a great era just to
explore data i completely agree because
i think it also makes it so we don't
have to have so much obsession over how
these characters look live you know what
i mean right we can animate them and it
can people can just kind of let go of
that because i feel like it's a default
criticism that i've been guilty of as
well where it's like oh it doesn't look
like the way i want it to look whereas
in animation you can set something the
characters obviously don't age unless
they the artists want them to it just
makes it easier to focus on the story
and the voice performance so i'm all in
on that eric i agree uh all right so
we're gonna ask a few more questions
that we had coming now that will be like
kenobi finale but first we want to thank
mint mobile for sponsoring this episode
if you are tired of fine print contracts
and getting ripped off by big wireless
providers for your cell phone service
then maybe it is time for a switch mint
mobile offers premium wireless starting
at just 15 bucks a month they are the
first company to sell wireless service
online only they cut out the cost of
retail stores and pass those sweet
savings directly to you and the best
part is there's no catch unlike when you
make a deal with the empire there's
always catches right mint mobile gives
you the best rate whether you're buying
for one or for a family and at mint they
only start at two lines all plants come
with unlimited talk and text plus
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network we have
several members of the new rockstar
staff that use mint mobile editor riley
got to use his own phone and keep the
same phone number along with all of his
existing contacts and phillip loves the
premium service that he gets from his
mint mobile account so switch to mint
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month get the new plan and get the
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com wookie that's
mintmobile.com
w-o-o-k-i-e-e
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mid-mobile.com wookie all right
tommy back to this obi-wan finale i want
to ask you why do you think obi-wan
spared vader what he had an opportunity
to kill him off why didn't he do you
know we talked about it in the office
and i talked about it on the break room
a little bit and i think that as crazy
as it sounds obi-wan felt an obligation
to kill anakin skywalker and once anakin
skywalker told him that that vader him
as as obtuse as it sounds that he as
darth vader had killed the last of
anakin skywalker obi-wan kind of like it
kind of defeated his will you know what
i mean like it was kind of like
okay
i don't need to kill you then it all is
lost you know what i mean i think he
wasn't thinking straight because if he
thought straight then it would have been
like
uh well we could prevent this guy from
killing a ton of more people but i think
he was so devastated by that line that
it obscured him whereas anakin when he's
upset his his instinct is to kill i feel
like obi-wan's is like a feeling of
helplessness that's when he's least
focused when he's thrown off like that
whereas anakin is blinded by rage he's
blinded by despair
if that makes sense yeah i agree i think
that's a great read of it tommy i think
there might also be something with uh
fear i think he was worried if he got
that close to him yeah like that vader
could like force choke him he could
strike at him like in order to actually
finish him off yeah that that might
damage him in either physical way or
like in a spiritual way that it might
break his soul even more like he might
be haunted with
with he was at a place of closure in
that moment just knowing that vader
killed killed him and at that point he's
like he's like all right i can walk yeah
i still cannot
i still have a problem with obi-wan
walking yeah knowing how much of a war
criminal
i think so i think that's the hardest
thing to logically
separate i think they need to
they need to cover that in like either
you know whether they they you know
clean it up in post interviews or they
clean it up in in a uh a
whatever comes next that does need to be
addressed yeah i think it is satisfying
i'm comfortable calling it a failure of
this show because to me that's like the
simplest question coming into the series
how can we make these two characters
fight
but still able to walk away from this
fight so that they have a rematch on the
death star like to me that's at the top
of the list and to me like that
conversation did not properly address
why he just didn't kill him off in that
scene like i understand if there's like
a physical barrier or if like the nature
around them forces them apart if it's
just like the chaos of it they are not
able to finish each other off makes
perfect sense to me but this he like
chose to walk away and they did not
properly explain why he made that choice
knowing what he knows obi-wan witnessed
him murdering civilians innocent people
everywhere yeah he knows how evil this
guy is this is a huge win and it and it
like he at least has to be worried about
leia and luke's future uh that vader is
still out there
wouldn't this be an opportunity just to
like protect those kids from this
monster right just to put them down
right yeah absolutely i have an issue
with it he should have killed him he
should have killed him absolutely should
have killed him as vader even said you
should have killed me when you had the
chance and i understand for star wars
continuity we have a whole sequel we
have a whole original trilogy where that
can't be the case but it's just like
yeah you couldn't come up with any
reason to do it better they needed to
like make it so like obi-wan was so they
needed to injure him you know or
something like or make him think he
killed him again yeah i mean episode
three did a better job at least with
just like a burning pile of minerals
right that i'd be willing to accept i
mean i was at the end of episode i'm
like okay well those flames are pretty
high
you know um but anyway uh all right last
question do you think obi-wan will see
leia again before the death star is
there going to be some other storyline
that uh where those two cross paths i
really hope so
i just want to see i mean i guess
i love what we got from this season i
don't know if we need them to though you
know i think what they had was so
meaningful that that would compel her to
to
plead for his help in a new hope you
know what i mean like she obviously
now has this great
reverence and love for this person as
like you know as a as a person who saved
her you know so
i i i think that we that we don't
necessarily need it but yeah i hope they
do just because i like happy endings you
know i hope so too just because or at
least i hope we get something that kind
of um revisits that look that leia gives
obi-wan on the death star
it just gives it some context yes you
know this could be something visited in
any series just like a moment yeah
between the two of them now obviously
carrie fisher alec guinness would not be
able to act in that way but you'd have
to bring other actors to do it you and
mcgregor and family or blair but uh i
think there's like ways you can do it
either through animation you know
through a comic i just want a bit more
now that we have this great context
between the two where they share this
together well we will leave it there for
this episode of wikileaks don't forget
to check out our merch options at
newarkstarsmerch.com follow me at ea
boss follow tommy tell me back to
probably new rockstar subscribe to
wikileaks wherever you get your podcast
we will see you next week we're going to
do this every week until we get to andor
uh but again we thank you for joining us
this week we have spoken
you